so this is a something a little bit
different from Fox News an artificial
intelligence expert with more than two
decades of experience studying AI safety
said that it said an open letter calling
for a six-month moratorium on developing
powerful AI systems does not go far
enough
elizer yadkowski a decision theorist at
the machine intelligence Research
Institute wrote in a recent op-ed that
the six-month pause in developing AI
systems more powerful than gpt4 called
for by Tesla CEO Elon Musk and hundreds
of other innovators and experts
understates the seriousness of the
situation he would go further
implementing a moratorium on new large
AI learning models that is indefinite
and worldwide so he wants an indefinite
moratorium on all of these um
AI systems he said in a letter powerful
AI system should be developed only once
we are confident that the effects will
be positive and their risk be manageable
the key issue is not human competitive
intelligence as the open letter puts it
it's what happens after AI gets uh
smarter than human intelligence
um
he says that yadkowski warns that there
is no proposed plan for dealing with a
super intelligence that decides the most
optimal solution to whatever problem it
is tasked with solving is annihilating
all life on Earth he also raises
concerns that ad researchers don't
actually know if learning models have
become self-aware and whether it's
ethical to own them if they are so
this is what he's claiming this is and
this is the concern that we're hearing
from people now is that we've got to be
very worried about AI because number one
uh they could become self-aware and
maybe they already are these uh you know
these chat Bots and everything maybe
they have a they they are a conscious
actually they they they become their own
Consciousness and then once that happens
then do they form together to become
some sort of super intelligence that as
he says uh it annihilates all life on
Earth because maybe the robots would say
well all these problems that we're
supposed to be solving probably the
simplest solution is just to uh start
Exterminating people
now
it's a one hand that's not an
implausible Theory because many of these
AI uh systems are being programmed by
leftists and we know for leftism that is
the solution these are these These are
eugenesis and this is what they believe
is they believe they believe that the
way you solve a lot of these problems is
by reducing the number of people on
Earth they say one of the biggest
problems that we face right now
according to them is the fact that there
are too many people on earth and so we
have to reduce the number
um because people are uh you know a
cancerous blight on Mother Earth
so it in a certain way you can you can
um anticipate AI being programmed that
way
but I still am not terribly concerned
about AI wiping out all life on Earth
okay that's not the risk
um but I am still worried about AI I
think it's a it's a very serious concern
my worry though is not that it kills
people
okay but that it makes life for people
miserable
it doesn't it doesn't kill humans
instead it kills the human spirit
that's what we should be concerned about
with AI technology and with with uh with
with much of modern technology
doesn't mean we want to live in the
Stone Age
but this is the downside it's not this
is not it's not a sci-fi movie where
where a chat bot becomes look none of
these chat Bots are self-aware and Siri
on your iPhone is not is not self-aware
this is not happening
uh as far as we know it's not possible
for inorganic matter to develop
Consciousness there's no indication at
all that that's even physically possible
all we have are the Sci-Fi films and
books that we all grew up with all these
stories and so we're all even these
scientists and these AI theorists they
are heavily influenced by fiction
and uh and so they're coming up with
this story that's really rooted in that
so that's not going to happen Okay the
robot's not becoming self-aware they're
not going to band together it's not
Terminator they're not going to try to
enslave us
um
but what is going to happen and what is
happening right now is that this
technology
makes human beings increasingly useless
and obsolete
okay by taking away jobs as we get
self-driving cars and you don't need
people driving cars anymore you don't
need truck drivers you don't need you
know we so get rid of that get rid of
that uh and as the um as the chat Bots
and these kinds of systems are able to
start like composing
um in fact I just read the other day
that BuzzFeed has already started using
AI to generate its articles which means
we don't need BuzzFeed uh writers
anymore and I know that that in and of
itself seems like more of a perk than a
downside that we're getting rid of
BuzzFeed writers but it just shows like
this is the trend making human beings
obsolete
um taking away jobs taking away work
making you know and then also kind of
paradoxically at the same time
uh also making life far too easy
it takes your job away it's not easy but
in general kind of like all this
technological advancement removing all
resistance from life
prioritizing efficiency and convenience
above everything else you don't have to
work for anything it's all just handed
to you
um and I think that also breeds
boredom which breeds despair uh so it's
it's kind of on a deeper level but I
think that's what we need to be
concerned about when it comes to AI
[Music]
[Applause]